no hay tregua en el quinto día de
bombardeos israelíes en la franja de
gaza y el lanzamiento de cohetes de la
yihat islámica Palestina pese a los
renovados intentos de mediación de
Egipto apenas 8 horas duró Esta última
pausa del fuego cruzado que llevan curso
Desde la madrugada y de ambos lados se
declaran listos para continuar con estos
enfrentamientos aunque no hay reportes
de nuevas víctimas la llamada operación
israelí escudo y flecha ha causado la
muerte de 33 palestinos entre ellos 15
civiles seis de ellos niños a los que el
jueves se sumó una mujer israelí que
falleció por el impacto de un cohete
estos ataques aéreos israelíes han
golpeado con fuerza la yihad islámica
matando a seis altos mandos el último un
jefe de operaciones que murió ayer en un
bombardeo de un edificio Residencial
según el ejército israelí más de 300
instalaciones del grupo han sido
destruidas y esta respondido con más de
mil proyectiles hacia Israel una
situación que ha llevado a que por
primera vez los movimientos de protesta
en Israel hayan decidido Cancelar las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales que
hasta ahora acumulaban unos 18 sábados
consecutivos entre tanto en la franja de
gaza la autoridad de energía ha
advertido que en las próximas 48 horas
la falta de combustible podría dejar sin
funcionar a la única planta eléctrica
del enclave agudizando aún más los
habituales cortes de luz fundamentales
ahora para los hospitales calzatíes al
mismo tiempo el ejército israelí no ha
cesado en sus redadas casi diarias en
cisjordania ocupada esta mañana dos
palestinos armados murieron en el campo
de refugiados de balata en el área de
nablus en medio de un fuerte intercambio
de disparos y así en lo que va de año ya
son más de 140 los palestinos muertos
por fuego israelí en cisjordania ocupada